bowling alley maid service all the
bowling balls are pink all made service
and they come up and they give so the
ball does
your hand
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boys today we have David's show
with us oh hello
and uh we asked our our resident shoe
expert Norman Lee to come through
because uh last time he was here you
might remember that we discovered he was
the owner of Golden Mile bowling which
is the bowling alley very close by and
we [__] that place up
you're the one with the [__] viral
video of chucking the bowling balls
overhand over him I mean he's right here
if you want to settle that right now who
who [__] up the bowling alley more
mirror there was a little crack in them
they [__] it up so bad though they
made the roof break
oh yeah you literally just spoiler
alerts hold here
well he's here because something
happened to that bowling alley uh last
week was it oh somebody got murdered yes
like a week and a half ago they had a
Bowling Championship and one guy was
like I did the strike [__] why would
you have to like prove it
[Laughter]
at the bowling alley no but there's been
like not fights but people have
threatened me before what what do they
say who does that like that was my
strike [__] most of the time it's
because they get drunk so it's not over
actual bowling no no you guys know John
Hall I mean yeah yeah he used to go all
the time and he would fight you no no
okay
yo what the he starts scrubbing his [__]
the [__] out of here socks you in the
face
the whole place
stop stopping on the [__] floor it's
like a group of guys next to him
um and his I guess his ex or something
but they were bowling and then he was
like they were yelling at John and them
bowling for some reason so I had a
manager so I had to go out there and
stop him and then he pulled out he just
like showed his sleeves some tattoo on
he's like you know what this is and I'm
like I don't know how to read it I got
tattoos too okay yeah you're [__]
sweet this says honorable Integrity
handsome yeah
or something and then he was trying to
say he was in a gang cancel but I was
just like
gang I don't know yeah it's like what's
good keep it ambiguous yeah because I
was just I was kind of trolling us we
don't meet this [__]
I'm sorry here's the formula you do the
math
it's like you want some trouble slope
intercept form
spread out the worst gangster ever dude
it's so exhausting and [__] you know
what this means
Crouching Tiger wrong
somebody's fighting in the gym listen
ing actors you and I are fighting in the
gym right and I want you to the bowling
in the bowling alley or in the gym no in
in the gym bowling alley
barbell bowling [__] so you and I are
fighting all right what
um we're fighting over hey your shit's
in my Lane okay hey you're shit's in my
Lane yeah so
you've been stalking me you want this
Korean dick
what are you doing something owner
no I haven't guessed it yet shove your
tattoos hey you want to see my face
your face plus my fist equals if a tree
fall in the forest I can't see the rest
I'm taking the clothes off you want to
see more of my tattoo once you see more
this [__]
you know what this means you know what
this means
with your turns up
so sorry I'm so sorry I've only been
here twice and I've seen three sets of
nipples
that's a good number
splash of tattoo
John and John no not me because I
stepped in oh because you were trying to
do this and he did this to you yeah wait
wait you know what game this one is I so
just really wish you said John did that
to you I'll be like this is a good story
yeah he just flashed the tattoo and then
he kind of like shoved me and just
getting in front of me yeah he knew you
were the owner or just like some guy no
he didn't know he just thought it worked
and then what'd you do did you [__]
twist his ear and be like I'm a spank
your ass Hobby
bigger than me I'm little well how tall
are you five nine oh you're not that
little though that's not little dude
that's like that's pretty you're bigger
than me I mean he was under six but he
was just like oh he's like yeah oh [__]
boy yeah he was a big guy is your name
Derek I don't know his name
is every big guy nb359 and under six
[Laughter]
how did you [__] diffuse the whole
thing uh I think he had one friend that
was outside that was kind of the not
Destiny driver or whatever so he came in
and kind of stopped it reason yeah and
he showed him his tattoo and they
communicated
[Laughter]
oh wait was it a Mexican guy with a
Chinese tattoo
you're saying there's buff guys out
there that get tattoos and don't know
what they mean on their shins no one
does that he said he was a Viet gang
which oh not Derek was in Vietnamese no
okay so and I was just like ah
maybe he was just asking you because you
look Chinese he goes you gotta tell me
man what this man yeah people just ask
me for help but he got mad because you
wouldn't help him maybe you're the
[__] in the story
he was giving you a sign I'm a gang
slavery man they bring me here shut me
out come on man they tattooed this it's
a cry for help just really badly done I
feel like a lot of gangsters did Bowl
though back in the day hell yeah yeah
because there was always a pool hall
Ellen Kim says there were lots of
rumbles at the point I've never met I've
never met a gangster that like asked
someone else to read though yeah that's
even if they were drunk is that new wave
that's a gen Z gangster yeah that's
something that's a wannabe that sounds
like some wannabe [__] or is that just
like super hardcore old school gangsters
like I can't read so can you read this
no you just pulled the gun out and then
get out of my Lane
you know what this mean danger
is that the end of that altercation that
was John had played no other no he he
kept going because his friends took him
out
[Laughter]
just bull yeah that sucks that's hard
managing a bowling all these yeah
there's no security guy is there he is
the security guy me and my brother
really why don't you hire a security guy
uh because my brother's big enough I
mean he's like five eleven but he's just
a big big dude wait isn't he Derek
Derek did you guys did you guys run the
bowling alley during the gang era of sgv
or was that your parents we took over
2013 so no oh because when I was going
around there was always fights and stuff
going down at the bowling alley at my
parents place there was always a gang of
three outside of our house but they they
just wanted to watch me play with they
say they're gonna blow your house down I
talked with them they're just like
you're just entertainment while we're
chatting and I'm like okay why did your
brother get socked in his face another
drunk dude oh my God
okay you guys still survive all over
there uh well we're close now and why
are you close I was like I'm trying to
try to get this back in track you know
that's the whole point of this video so
yeah something happened to to our
beloved local bowling alley besides
before you guys went there uh do you
have the video on your phone show David
what happened to it well I want to see
and then the people on without watching
are gonna see it in another little
window oh yeah
um okay well actually I don't think you
guys have seen this one either I'd
rather see his reaction to it first time
fight
this guy crumping in there
what the [__]
this is the front entrance going in oh
no yeah so is that from all the Rings I
don't know if you guys it is oh
my God yeah I didn't post that but
that's it all Hambra I didn't know it
rained that much yeah okay it was rough
[__] I didn't get a video of it actually
breaking yeah my sister's like checking
because you might have it do you have
photos of the hole okay yeah yeah dude
that was that's not like that whole
crazy it's like 30 by 30 or something
like that so because of all the
torrential downpour and the rain last
week the weight of the water on the roof
was it just eventually like broke it
through oh my God look at that dude what
the [__] yeah so it was pulling on the
top and then it just too heavy is that
something that insurance can cover yeah
so luckily that's that's why I started
showing I was like I don't care if I
show it anymore they approved oh nice
that's crazy because nobody gets rain or
water damage insurance in California or
L.A because they're just like that
should never have let's say you didn't
have insurance what would that be out of
pocket cost be my agent told me that it
might have been over 200k oh my God what
a goddamn roof yeah
[__] what that's crazy
oh my God
why would 200k hey what is expensive out
in these days you know because you have
to also redo a lot of the walls a lot of
the structure is kind of messed up so
they have to do a lot of structural
stuff we'll get you get to actually get
it up to code now brand new [__] yeah
yeah so there's now it's super old it's
a super old building so it's really not
up to code so I'm gonna have to go
through the city and get all permitted
did you do the Asian thing with one of
your family members is like oh red hurt
my neck too I'm a chiropractic [__]
Services you know we were actually on
top of the the roof because we're gonna
go drain the pool and then you guys fell
in too we almost did though oh as soon
as we got to the top we turned around
and the whole thing just dropped whoa
what if you guys should fall in and get
half a million dollars yeah we should we
can we can cut this part out of the
video we restart it over and be like you
fell in and yeah
I
wish you so funny on video no no you're
being hurt but that would be really fun
for us the hole is oh I didn't show you
the other side it would look like where
your brother felt
like the end of the one of those Tijuana
water slides
that was the because our side is the
smaller hole there's a huge hole on the
other side
other side who's the other side what
what establishment was over there
Raising Canes no it's just the other
room was like this oh [__] is that the
pool hall or the bar yeah oh no and we
were this close of doing JK news there I
know that's what I was thinking too and
I was I was going to start up we did do
Jake and oh my neck was from The Ring
give me a hundred thousand dollars hey
good thing you didn't have other
customers there blaming you for
something that happened that's true so
this off hours when it happened uh no we
I just opened
um so we had people in there was a
league that was about to start and then
everything just went wrong no we were
talking about getting the JK news office
in that room with the Cape Town oh
that's right yeah we would have had all
this equipment just smashed down
that's the worst idea ever dude
every day
why can't you read
I don't know Chinese I've been
pumping the whole place stop stop
that should take place from the new like
people completed it's loud and it scares
them I know you think that scares you
check one out wait till you get this
John hall.wave
it's not even him so the bowling alley
is still going to be up after you fix
everything
there should be a massive gutter ball
you could get I mean technically we can
uh but we don't really want to you don't
want to reopen Golden Mile so fix it fix
it and sell it uh that or we'll try to
sell it where my brother my brother's so
as is with the whole no no yeah they're
gonna show up to Deja Vu
let's go that's a thick ass Pole
we're trying to see if we can do
something else there I want to keep the
building yes have someone else to do
something else there instead Esports
don't say Esports no but but the bad
internet cafe the back of the bowling
alley that has all that Machinery that
shoots the ball back isn't that worth
something like yeah we can probably sell
them like there's probably other bowling
alleys that'll come pick it up open a
japanese-made cafe there are so many
creepy little leaves out in that area
dude they would [__] you would make so
much money they would [__] you amazing
weedy ass greasy little virgins dude I
have a friend that's a show that I used
to be dude
no seriously because I um and make us
VIPs there got it I went to so so Tim
and I do this thing at this Anime Expo
and there was like the the Japanese made
Cafe where they've had you know it's
they don't speak Japanese but it's
people who like anime and Japanese are
they even Japanese or like Vietnamese or
whatever they're all white
it's not for me right but I I do know
that a lot of people enjoy that [__]
like there was like a waitlist people
signed up to sit down and get served by
them yeah and you know they're obviously
doing it's a very Niche like what are
they serving they're just shitty ass
cakes and croissants that they got from
Vons so it's really it doesn't matter
it's just about the the aesthetic and
the environment so it's so literally
it's you know if you've ever watched
anime you'll see like these bubbly
little girls who are like okay
they didn't expect it to be like that
right they got them Heavies though right
no they did not they had heavy makeup
though you know what I'm saying but no
they're very sweet I don't want to say
that cut that out no keep it in it's
real okay they they would walk up and
they come in hi oh my God it's I'm so
glad to see you how are you I was so
[__] uncomfortable right but people
love that experience it's just not for
sure yeah is that when we went to the
cafe in Japan hello I am a nasty we went
to the monster Cafe it's the Kawaii
monster Cafe
well it was a guy he came out and he
goes hello
should totally be the manager at a
japanese-made cafe yeah you should be
nasty dude I'll have a [__] eye patch
and [__] you open a Japanese made Cafe I
guarantee you balling out crazy just had
good coffee good drinks and just a bunch
of people pastries from Vons pastries
from Vons they don't give a [__] about
the food they just care about that
experience where you get treated like
you're the hottest guy on Earth I'm
hearing good metrics man yep good
conversions gotta be good money or else
I don't know how I'm gonna do that
because that like you said is
uncomfortable but you see it's like the
Vietnamese cafe minus the nudity yeah
and then the girls do performances too
where they have like dance
it's just making you not want it more no
yeah it's really not he's selling it hey
you said until these pockets are heavy
like some titties you know what I'm
saying we've got six locations yeah the
only tattoos you'll be seeing on [__]
you know what I'm saying
are the guys all are the are the guys
all wearing Naruto outfits and stuff
it's you know what I'll say this man
what I love about anime Expos is that I
feel like these people don't get to
really be themselves until they're in
this area watching them that happy made
me happy right because I know for a fact
that listen they're not when you go
outside in the real world and you you
express all these things that you like
that people don't enjoy they're afraid
to get picked on but over here the music
is going on they know every K-pop dance
and [__] you know they're doing all this
stuff they look at somebody else they go
world and they look so [__] happy
that made me real they're not hurting
anybody exactly and they get to really
be like as dweebie and nerdy as they are
absolutely and they just like that no
wedgies to follow no wedges
nobody's getting beat up nobody is
judging them except for me and it's just
quietly it's really nice because I but
anime nowadays is super in it's very in
like I'm talking about even like Street
culture in like every like major
basketball player and it felt like
they're very Pro yeah but they're like
on the fringes of anime liking right so
they like the popular yeah these people
are in it in it they dress uh like
left-wing anime yeah
man I saw somebody in like this uh
outfit it had to be I mean I'm guessing
he's probably spent thousands of dollars
on that [__] and they wait for this
moment for them to be there and then
people come up to him like Hey can I
take a photo with you and you see them
light up made me feel really [__]
good hey you know what yeah it's their
burning man that's like that's like
Renaissance that's a really good it's
their burning man it's like their moment
you know by the way this day was [__]
raining up it was the worst day of my
life because me and Tim were so [__]
stupid we saw the we saw the weather we
saw everything else it was pouring rain
we have to do a food show we have no
coat no nothing I wore a hoodie what
happens when when water touches a
[__] hoodie so we barely filmed
[__] anything the worst day of my
life but watching these people enjoy
themselves made me really fun and happy
man it was really cool you guys deserve
the best all you guys the comments if
you think it should be turned into one
of these made clubs let them know and if
you have any other suggestions what
could Golden Mile bowling become next
bowling alley [__] made oh yeah
because when they Bowl you could they
bend over a little I don't know if we're
listening to the fact that he neither
wants to run a bowling alley or a maid
shop yet so combine them oh word genius
hey in the comments below tell me you
guys don't want a bowling alley maid
service all the bowling balls are pink
all made service and they come up and
they give so the ball doesn't come back
from a mechanism someone brings it back
yeah they go like this
very good
[Music]
foreign